Babbitt's pumped he got some good
content for dailyvee I'm like sweating
I turned it into like an awesome track
I'm driving back come back neither like
a visible adoptee with clarity like my
name is Derrick Thomas I've been telling
you
accountants of equity I'll triple they
given a pedigree Sabina no pleasure my
fantasy
[Music]
[Music]
yep yeah my name's Paul I bought you
thank you um I know you're pretty nice
everybody but uh I'll just want to if I
get a picture
shoot man okay cool all right sweet have
a good trip thanks man external off if I
were to reach out
Paul Royal but use the pictures okay
yeah awesome thank you
yeah write me up I know you're doing the
whole penis in one yep yep on the dude
this is awesome at about that no yeah
you're having a meeting Tuesday with the
things that have been vetted through
okay all right look you know what take
this picture and and send it to me
tonight and then I'll use that to make
sure that they're you know that you're
in that consideration set on their
father gives you so much life like a
miniature quick yeah sure yo the video
one quick thing what's your positivity
hack in life gratitude you know I'm just
very grateful I know what you know I
know what the world is about some sort
of grateful yeah I appreciate you not
saying again
sorry good for a year man thank you Mary
Kelly thank you Paul something else
where no thank you
I'm going to try and then do a nice
media surreal like they're going to get
this short awesome on this is it on logs
oh yeah real pleasure it makes me to
take here thank you
I show you thank you thank you
that's because that kind of sick ones
hasn't happened yet the slammer in
Denver going to two client meetings and
then internal meeting with video
production and creative so that can be
productive also just put out a pretty
good post about the podcast a lot of
feedback for people that aren't able to
keep up with videos as a new job or new
kids or things of that nature so make
sure you get a podcast train every
format such as iTunes SoundCloud Spotify
iHeartRadio overcast stitcher doing it
all so you can listen
like yes maybe I was the lighter fluid
on a lot of these guys who were already
putting in real business work I mean
there's a lot of people picked up crush
it and it's gonna take people the reason
I always talk about patience is I don't
know if you were born entrepreneur or
have been doing it for a long time if
you're coming from I've been a 17-year
lawyer but I love candle making and I'm
going to become the candle guy right
like like you're going to be starting
from a zero place from entrepreneurship
it may take two and a half three years
you clip this audio part from you
recording right now and send it to my
team because I want because I want to
use it in the pre-roll of the video for
so they could hear when this got figured
out cool so yeah so so on that point I'm
going to tell you something that's
really scary to me I'm not so sold that
the only thing I am doing is actually
giving people permission I think through
my own confidence and my complete utter
lack of being worried about what other
people think when I'm in my zone in the
business world right that my confidence
and bravado is creating a shield for a
lot of people to take the leap and all
of a sudden it's literally literally I
feel like I'm a swim coach and I'm just
pushing people into a pool they start
swimming and they're like oh wait a
minute I can [ __ ] swim yeah I think I
think the lesson there is like hey if
some of you are actually doing well on
the side if you've got a great t-shirt
business and it was about the business
and you like t-shirts the value 34 and
actually you're like you know what I
really like gardening like why not like
it's crush it on crush it right like
okay it's not being it's not being a
lawyer and then starting a t-shirt
business on the side it's now you
actually did that but you just realized
wait a minute eight years later actually
like gardening why can't you start the
gardening business on the side while
you're doing t-shirt business and
eventually becomes the gardening
business
good stuff good stuff middle shower and
what I can tell you is if I ran their
company next year they would do 11
million in revenue from one and they're
going to do three and that's all that we
have to think about go to lunch meeting
with a client Little Lulu vbq living the
dream slide them down driveways make it
business happening brother's children
but how realistic is this like is this
really really could people really do
this it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] fabric
real like it's like the ambition of the
majority
it's the ambition of probably 20% of the
use of America to basically live the
crush it light that's a that's a
astonishing situation it just becomes
very real because of the emergence of
podcast you to the explosion of YouTube
and the explosion of Instagram the three
current platforms are like those
recurring platforms and Facebook - but
like those I guess it's a tipping point
I think we're in it now this is so pump
up the visuals you're getting okay
[Music]
Mack so much
[Music]
and you were out in New York like a
couple months ago and you so we got
together while we were talking we start
talking about this idea
I like how you showing it in the email
like it's a tracing just help sell I
agree
just helps right yeah these guys are
good no sure no but you know what I mean
that just it just helps sell that does
the feeds yeah mm-hmm we reverse
engineered that a little bit yes there's
clearly was at some point somebody who
is the most famous first person to do it
but that just really was pure virality
look skin face it's face book it's way
more replicatable than people think if
the problem is everybody tries to make
it like let's eat the peanut butter [ __ ]
like they what people don't realize is
when you have to replicate something
that's replicatable you have to walk
away from it like in the way that we all
thought teen spirit you can't do that
because everything looks like the ice
bucket challenge which means it's not
good you have to take that you have to
take the feed of what makes an ice
bucket challenge but you can't make it
like you can't make it like a challenge
you have to make it like let's all hold
hands across America right now go like I
just start like it's got to have the
cymatics of it but not look like it yeah
see you later yeah take your selfie
cigars yes yeah awesome awesome hello
guys
if you're in a folder negative happened
with the development to client meetings
productive trial you're joining a
threatening just had very senior meeting
with the head of our video production
are not creative chaser than that indeed
and I just love them leadership meetings
were where we're trying to do what's
right for the logo everybody have you
know kind of like tiny head coach and
they're an offensive and defensive
coordinator so of course they care about
the football team they can't help but
caring about their squad their players
that are part of it and I have a lot of
empathy for that in my leadership team I
never asked them to do what I'm supposed
to do I'm supposed to take care of and
care about and think about the whole
they are supposed to take and think
about their team but when I bring them
to the table like a day we need to think
about the entire bozo so very productive
but we got a lot done it was key for
leaders out there when they are having
these meetings is what are you doing
before that meeting
what I tend to do as the leader
abilities been able to bill from
existences and having a lot of small
little meetings and some exchanges with
these leaders and moving them down the
field before we get there so they don't
spend two hours being very far apart we
get here and then it's really just about
that hard right just just take over I
don't have any white spaces you've got
to hear what that good was that I took
they make you seriously no questions of
mine say thank you thank you my guard me
in my can say word yeah just thank you
what's your name like Kenny I would had
my phone died because it's so cold I
wish I had a picture of it come on
no no I got you yeah just thank you so
much clear what's your what's your email
or game oh thank you yeah amazing thank
you so we got it
the key is if you have big meaning
restructure strategies trying to get
people lined you can't allow those
people to start off here and then try to
make that whole meet and get you all the
way here you'll never get there so what
I try to do is those days and wink
music I'm working on this and then I
close the gap so what happens in a very
productive
unfortunately it shared much less we all
because insects are just hundreds of
people in my organization but is not
given to the
one hidden thing from dailyvee even
though I'm showing it more than anybody
allow us to be fly-on-the-wall these
readings exactly things can show
everything but but I think that
eventually it will what regular
disbelief all the concept you know in
10-15 years they have a stuff anyway I
appreciated that the apartment journey
the climate vlogs but everyday thing
I just think that eventually people
understand it one things when you guys
have this figured out of episode 160-170
another thing for this thing to be
secured out of episode 11000
[Music]
you